guillaume blais et courrier à vélo
depuis 1997 à montréal 23 ans à respirer
l'air pollué de la ville mais la baisse
de circulation causés par la pandémie a
apporté un vent de fraîcheur à son
travail se sont se rendait pas compte
qu'il a toujours la main on respire on
emmène tout le bouddha la campagne
environnement canada confirme que l'ère
de montréal est plus pur ce printemps
entre autres parce que les voitures qui
produisent 25 % des gaz à effet de serre
au québec ont presque disparu des rues
de la métropole
on peut estimer que c'est environ 50%
des ventes d'essence qui ont chuté en a
en mars et en avril pour le québec ce
serait environ 2 millions de gaz à effet
de serre en moins juste pour mars avril
ce qui est quand même une grosse
quantité parce que au québec on émet un
grosso modo 80 millions de tonnes et
avec le ralentissement économique qui
devrait se poursuivre pierre olivier
pineau croit que le québec s'approchera
de sa cible de réduction des gaz à effet
de serre pour 2020
mais comme la crise est temporaire
comment imaginer des améliorations à
plus long terme il ya des gens qui vont
vouloir rester à la maison les
entreprises qui vont vouloir faire plus
de télétravail et ça ça va avoir un
impact direct sur les ventes d'essence
et sur un terrain très en forme en ce
moment et comment vous trouvez
et ça dépend des jours mais généralement
j'aime quand même ça ne peut pas me
déranger bars et les collègues
pourraient différentes questions faire
toucher ça c'est bien pour se reposer
sur mes pas dû passer la journée vous
avez vous fait une story travail
malheureusement non si j'avais eu
l'occasion j'aurais fait et je pense que
c'était une chose positive
ça s'est bien passé grosso modo mais
j'ai hâte de retrouver le vrai travail
un sondage effectué en mai par la
chambre de commerce de montréal indique
que 59% des entreprises montréalaises
souhaite favoriser le télétravail pour
la majorité de leurs employés après la
pandémie
c'est le cas d'hydro québec qui compte
1700 employés à son siège social du
boulevard rené lévesque
depuis la mi mars voici à quoi ressemble
plusieurs de ses bureaux
aujourd'hui à travers la province dix
mille 500 employés diderot sont en
télétravail soit 54 % de toute sa main
d'oeuvre
on est en train de vraiment regarder
dans votre grande réflexion qu'on avait
déjà entamé il ya plusieurs mois mais
qu'il s'accélère avec le contexte pour
voir lorsqu'on reviendra à la normale
hydro québec n'exclut pas qu'une grande
majorité des employés en télétravail
aujourd'hui le demeure au moins quelques
jours par semaine il y aurait plusieurs
avantages
on a aussi plusieurs bureaux réaménagés
finalement en intégrant beaucoup plus le
télétravail fonds peut limiter les
déplacements dans le centre-ville
peut-être bouger en dehors des hommes de
grande circulation qu'au final ça donne
beaucoup plus de ressources aux employés
ainsi qu'à l'entreprise télétravail fait
des années qu'on dit voyons on veut
réduire le nombre de kilomètres
parcourus
voici une belle solution l'avancement
des horreurs même chose donc ses succès
positif
là on a les moyens la démonstration est
faite que ça peut fonctionner ce qui est
quand même incroyable
spécialiste des déplacements urbains
catherine morency viennent de terminer
une recherche sur le télétravail dans le
grand montréal
si on avait à chaque jour mais pour cent
des travailleurs qui ne soit déplacé peu
combatif travail on pourrait réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de 10
% sur une base annuelle difficile encore
d'évaluer combien de voitures pourraient
être retirés nos routes mais les heures
de pointe montréalaise s'annonce
peut-être moins difficile grâce au
télétravail
attention toutefois il y a des bémols le
premier risque c'est effectivement que
s'il ya moins d'automobiles sur la route
les temps de déplacement s'améliore ce
qui serait souhaitable mais pour qu'il
continue à s'améliorer faut éviter qui
est de plus en plus grands qui remise
par l'automobile
danger aussi d'encourager l'étalement
urbain si ceux qui travaillent à
montréal non plus à s'y rendre aussi
souvent bref encore beaucoup d'inconnues
mais si l'environnement avait besoin de
solutions draconiennes
le coronavirus aura au moins eu le
mérite de les provoquer